what up though my name is rule dude and
I'm about to answer the Internet if you
could have one person narrate do
play-by-play of you having sex who would
it be
who's the dude from Shawshank Redemption
Morgan Freeman yeah I'll definitely have
and now he's pushing her facing the
pillow and telling him to take this dick
would you rather have a dick as your
nose or a nose as you dick I got a
big-ass nose
I'm gonna go nose dick and just eat
[ __ ] after I feel like it's hard to get
a job a dick on your face if you entered
a beauty pageant what would your talent
be [ __ ] yo-yo I'm gonna walk the dog
around the world make that [ __ ] sleep
rock the cradle yeah [ __ ] nice with
it which group of people are the worst
people who clap at the end of a flight
or the end of the movie I never thought
about this I hate them equally but that
airplane [ __ ] like theirs Wow like I get
it was like 1910 or whatever but like
bro we've been flying it's usually some
cats from the islands or corny white
people if you could only watch one
category of porn for the rest of your
life what would it be
[ __ ] I don't know dude it gets dark I
really like I any-anything wearing like
they take somebody nice and turn them
into something awful degradation porn
I'm aroused Washington like porn and
like I had to stop by the time because
he was like Washington's wife get [ __ ]
through the window
they wouldn't even let him be in the
room I was like I gotta stop dude if you
had the flexibility to blow yourself
would you what if everybody knew you did
it's a good [ __ ] question
I don't know bro one time I accidentally
tasted my own come like I'm not a fast
on my girl I want to like try to make up
for it like histor and I got it in my
mouth and I'm like oh it was [ __ ]
awful like no wonder they don't like
swallowing this [ __ ] and I got a tingle
it on my lips and I like I jumped out
the car I hate snow no and now I keep
the car yeah I was see him pick me up he
had just picked me up from bed I picked
her up from the airport I ain't seen her
in a minute so like I pulled over on the
side of the street just to [ __ ] and
like busted mad quick like I'm sorry
I'll make it up to you kiss-kiss kids
come out snow so that's gonna be a note
that was the longest no ever could you
beat up Tom Cruise I don't think I could
man I do I cannot bring something to hit
him with or do I just yeah I beat the
[ __ ] off him with that now he exercises
that [ __ ] got cardio I [ __ ]
gas man quick you get to marry the girl
of your dreams but you have to watch
your biggest enemy have sex with her
first do you do it I don't even have a
biggest enemy like who like we saw and I
just don't respect not at Bear dealers
dude I [ __ ] hate that guy either
fake-ass me like he like watch me jump
this trench in like they pulled back and
he's just jumping over a [ __ ] ditch
on the road so no I couldn't read I
could she wouldn't be she wouldn't be
the girl of my dreams as she [ __ ] bear
Gillis if if she [ __ ] somebody that I
had that little respect for so we'll
meet a girl of my dreams
she'd be
and if she was wearing ugg boots there
are two buttons one instantly gives you
a million dollars one gives you a 50/50
shot at a hundred million dollars
wouldn't you push of coin slip i well
i'm broke right now so I'll go with coin
flip
I'll do the coin flip I already know
what it feels like to be broke like
what's a million like a million ain't
like it was a million dollars [ __ ] in
1970 I'm taking the million dollars but
a million dollars bro like that's a
house where I live like it's like you
could buy a house but with [ __ ] 50
million dollar Oh hundred million
dollars I could be that's [ __ ] you money
last one like Kevin Hart he was all like
he got all that [ __ ] money I think he
apologized seven times for saying [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] a pig's orgasm laughs
over 30 minutes a line can have sex over
50 times per day which would you rather
be I want to be the line because you
ever like get your dick sucked and then
they keep sucking you're like you turn
like turn [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't want
to do that I just want I want to I want
a regular nut I take a woman's orgasm
they seem to have a good time but not a
pig would you rather watch your dad have
sex with the hundred year old man or
watch your mom kill someone
oh I get to pick who she kills sure she
kills bear Gillis that is name [ __ ] that
guy would you rather have sex with the
blind person or a deaf person I was just
talking about this I was I was just
talking about this not I feel like deaf
people have better sex because they
can't like you know like you're yourself
aware so like a book girl makes you like
do some sit where you like you won't say
it cuz you'll sound goofy but if you're
deaf you don't know how you sound like
you could really hello there get that
big bird so ya deaf all day cuz I feel
like they'll just have better sex but
you know here's other hands we [ __ ] that
y'all don't know like I was talking to a
deaf chick and it's hard like you can't
argue with them on the phone there's an
operator where you got to be like they
tell you what the deaf person says she's
like why don't you want to meet my mom
and I'll be like cuz I just want to
smash then you got to say over and then
so I just want to smash over and then
you got wait a minute like what I want
you to and they're like it's [ __ ] it
was a real headache but that was in like
oh one maybe he got better since then
yeah if you could wipe one group of
people off the earth who would it be
[Music]
the the type of person that needs to
tell me that they're unfollowing me on
instagram just [ __ ] off silently like a
grown up
you